Boris Johnson who nine months ago was
prime minister has quit as an MP
in a long angry statement he blamed the
Privileges committee that investigated
him over partygate on learning they
wanted to see him suspended for over 10
days which could have seen him kicked
out of the commons he stood down
branding it a kangaroo court he thrives
on the oxygen of publicity so what on
Earth he'll do next I do not know in
some ways I don't care but I do actually
because I care passionately about having
people involved in politics that are
decent and honest and honorable and
don't tell lies and that is not that man
Boris Johnson it comes amid a standoff
with the cabinet office over their
handling of his covid Communications
that has seen him once again in the
spotlight and his resignation honors
list added to the controversy with his
old Ally Nadine Doris denied a peerage
also dramatically standing down just
hours earlier in his statement he takes
aim at the current prime minister his
record on brexit and his part his lack
of ambition and things are about to get
worse for Rishi sunak with a by-election
now on the horizon that could inflict
another electoral wound on the
conservatives
in the final line of his statement Mr
Johnson says he's going at least for now
a message reminiscent of his last words
in the Commons as prime minister hasta
la vista baby a reminder to his Rivals
he may be leaving Parliament but Boris
Johnson's influence on British politics
is not going anywhere Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster